hello welcome to our
daily meeting for the press online and
live on the bs today is
Friday, January 8th
I take this opportunity to
wish live a happy birthday to dana
spina who I am sure is listening to us
as you saw this morning we
started the day with a
press conference from alain's presidency
about vaccines and now before
answering your questions i would also like to
share the president's agenda
for next week
nixon selected three students
participated via videoconference nba
nice planet summit which only took
place this weekend of these minors
photo ed wood christ was born according to the
weekend of low fare format york
washington
julian youtube
in five years next  a son of the
president in exile between johnnie to 1 3
and 5
before this date many extras yes
charlie one to one shot not enough of
six fours in crisis hindi you that
plastic arts therese it is necessary  that it will
have a context where from ska wandering
a shadow on wii and wii av and
frameworks which will provide does not care
about any vaccination in 10 against 8
gently
washington and its meetings tubes
all ages
two companies still a team remains
is in the casting  we get vaccinated vaccination
ok mass I have a question about
water vaccines
yes hello yes hello eric hello
everyone and my best wishes for a
happy new year
of course my bed with us bennati in
good it's legal and  here I I I
I followed
Mrs Van der Linde's press conference and
unfortunately I could not intervene for
technical reasons but I watched for
a precise moment when it would be a question
of international cooperation of
European solidarity in vain  so i
have the impression that it happens with
the vaccines as it happened with
the masks so we first try to
solve the problems at the internal level
the europeans use ab  ord and it's
only after we can think of countries
like africa
so I would like to see where you
stand in relation to the access of
vaccines to African countries and
what vaccines are all the same  not
mints years and to fight
against the commune 19 which has done a
lot of damage everywhere including
in africa
so I would like to know what you are
going to plan for your
African partners and the other one
question is to  to know if you are
aware of this kovacs initiative which
was launched by the ms to allow
poor countries to African countries
to have access to the vaccine
that is my question thank you thank you very much
to the masses for your questions which are
quite relevant  heart of the reflection the
strategic reflection of the president
since the very beginning of the pandemic and
before passing the floor to anna so
that we can reiterate here that it has
been our approach I would just like to
point out to hide the president has been u  ne
of the initiators of the initiative to
enable our partners our partner countries
to obtain vaccines under the
kovacs initiative and that the european union is a
very important contributor to
the kovacs initiative but I will hand over to anna
for  that she can answer in more
detail thank you very much
masson homme as eric said very
well I think it is very important to
say that the European Union is
determined to do everything it can
to contribute of course that  the comic
19 accent is accessible in
everyone and that's why we put
riscle said that the european union is
supporting very forming the
facility of kovacs european lines the
european investment bank
also including  our member states have already
made pledges of
more than 850 million euros for kovacs
is good we are of course not authorized to
speak on behalf of kovacs because for
that it is clear that they have that  is proper
eq  team to do it but just to
tell you that kovacs the objective of
kovacs and of course to be able to secure
more than 1 billion doses of vaccines
for the countries
[Music]
the countries income from income looting
thank you very much sorry for this little
school and  so the urban line support
for the
komax clashes on this and moreover, as you
know very well,
the agreements of the European union give
the possibility to the member states to be
able to share part of these two
with our partner countries and we have
already had the  opportunity this week already
to explain to you a little bit that we are
in the process of creating a mechanism
that can facilitate the donation or
the cessation of sales of vaccines as well as they
have been procured by our member states
within the iv timeframe of the agreements  of 2 hours in
this project it's griezmann sorry
but it doesn't come we bend in
french and the discussions are
still in progress with the member states
so let's stop discussions of course  r that
the commission is in the process of
facilitating but they are continuing on this but
it is clear that the mechanisms for
sharing would particularly
target health workers from
low-income countries and also people who are in
need of
humanitarian assistance and also of course including
our partners in the
western balkans and our neighborhood thank you
very much
ana so to sum up
effectively we have always
insisted on the fact that a
vaccination strategy could only ultimately
be successful if it  extended
to all countries
because we can all be sure
of having defeated the vaccine or each be
sure of having defeated the vaccine only when
we have all defeated the vaccine
together so we will continue our
efforts in this in  this direction
we continue on vaccines and I give
the floor to david yes thank you eric
calais thank you for bringing the
president to the press room to
answer  dre to our questions i wanted to
know bull todays announcement so
300 + 300 but 75 million doses
faiza biotech in second quarter 1
2021 is it would be impossible to
know how many doses will be
available for member states by here
at the end of the second semester
we are talking about 375 million or there are
other other figures to percy stéphane
hello david and mercy regarding
the delivery of these doses that we
indicated before regarding the
first 200  millions of bankrupt biotech
were all due to be delivered at the end of
the end of September 2010 is not
the West
from here we have done by September 2021
so the like you these deliveries take
place now and therefore from here  September
its 200 million will be delivered and then
there is the additional 100 million on
which we agreed to exercise
an option also doses of band x
files those will be delivered the second
part of the year we now have
today  today had the very  good news
of the 300 additional doses of which the
millions three hundred to three hundred
million and inflate the I am a
lawyer a game I do not calculate very well
so the 300 million doses of which the
first delivery will begin in the
second quarter of this year and
then  there are still the doses of moderna
for which deliveries will
begin next week and
will take place on the 1st 2nd 3rd and 4th
quarters of 2021
here we must not forget that
country-by-country delivery is
in fact determined by the country concerned and
the company  depending on
the country's vaccination strategies I
now turn the floor over to caroline delas
everything we could say andy fails
standing focus is on the rings datsyuk
trial this weekend his priests 9 so
strong in my little world is hungry we live
action  in contact with ovi vaccine
darcos libye
[Music]
we say that he means no every day
when i come back
exactly throughout the life story
[Mus  ique]
thomas it goes without saying this party is certainly
there was a barometer of the kof michel tour
to vaccinate their doors at rates
bearable by settings all the
same a context where there is camille country
and can cancel his idea on Saturday this
case  I smiled keeps a tourist plays there
one of canes or such a word from the field
radio dio to expectations is
great for me it's a shape so
they want exact bonus match of
saint tin followed exact squad of these
machines one one  day for women and
provide enthusiastic crowd sow or
another narizah fight
[Music]
you're happy new year and cost i would like to
know the lot the pfizer vaccine
a very sophisticated transport
and storage system
the european agency is in the process
to study other vaccine options
for which for the moment he has not
yet given an answer is that these
doubling of doses widens mans of
contract with pfizer to be followed
by other enlargements with other
vaccines  simpler ins or from the
moment we have already doubled with riser it
will not be necessary to make other
additional purchases thank you very much
thank you zelda I completely understand
the meaning of your question but you
will also understand that we are not coming
back  here in scenarios of what
might or might not happen in the future
I think the situation is very
fluid and the main thing is that we
remain reactive in relation to the
development that there may be on the
ground and depending on  the evolution
of the authorizations which are granted by
the european commission following the opinions
of the european medicines agency
we do not forbid ourselves anything in terms
of negotiation if the need
were to arise, of
course, but we do not  we are not going to negotiate
systematically simply for the fact
of negotiating which I believe we must
see how the situation evolves on the
ground and according to this the
commission will adapt its approach  oche
francesco
at his zelig hysteria at the
visa obligation legal tools strong of
czech comics beats the opéli obligation and is in
addition to and a half dose d you made you
seek woman of django 10 at the igas band
negotiating by the number  of simply
trideau 6 and feed everything ni di marco to
what complications fort-louis
announcements from other sites ontex wood
brothers racing in context of and if so
of the drunk says dos and vaccinations
necessary for peace
joong-ho china prestigious  which weighs
heavily in the dummy of a trip in
camera security rendered 2000 yen extract
diocese we are vaccinated open where
points wimbledon 2 us and coming in
focus on the situation is a rose has
been nantes negotiate x26 life a thing
of we continue to process christian  yes
hello in fact me what interests me
is another part of the intervention
of Mrs von der leyen because we
announce dose purchases we have
millions billions of doses
vaccinations it works  not and she said
two things that were interesting
and said the first
was vaccinations are going very slowly
the second she said that indeed
we are faced with an extension
of the contamination which is still very
important and so she said we  going to
have a difficult spring
everyone announces an autumn which is
also likely to be difficult
I would like to know on the 21st you have a
summit followed by ovide on the 21st building sites
it has just been announced from the other
side of the street you  as a
commission what are you going to
defend because you have
possibilities and things like everyone
else you can't do you
negotiate contracts but it's
member states if member states do
n't vaccinate doesn't happen  not to be vaccinated
who can't convince people
to be vaccinated is it all
not in vain does all this mean that we
will continue to talk to each other for
months and months and months in
videoconferencing  this because we will be
unable to have normal meetings again
because indeed this
contamination does not end and and the
return from the holidays is in the process
of flattening a certain number of countries,
Germany in particular.
italy spain so here is what you are
going to do on the 21st what
are you going to defend
how can we get out of
this kind of slump that
speaks to us about it and which has nothing to do  see with the 2
3 billion if we can't manage to
inject them we don't care about the 2.3 billion
excuse me but me that's what worries me
when are we going to get out of this
shitty situation the first  thing
christian if i can allow myself i completely
understand that we are
all confronted with a
difficult situation but try in a
program which is broadcast live to
moderate our vocabulary hainaut and noé
our words but on the substance of your
question
it is  true that the situation is
difficult and it is true that i  There is
no ready-made answer and this is
indeed the challenge facing
the European Union, its institutions
and the member states, they
also face researchers and
industrialists,
but when we are in the  adversity
as is currently the case
for europe there is no question of
giving up
there is no question of giving
up and the commission is committed to
taking the measures that are within its
remit  and moreover to take
completely innovative measures
compared to what it had done in the
past because the vaccine purchasing program
that we have implemented is
completely innovative compared to
what has been done in  the past in order to
gradually stem the pandemic and
with the member states of to defeat it
you refer to
difficulties in certain member states
with regard to vaccination
there are also successes in
vaccination
we are at the start of a process
he  of course, that the
member states are also flexible and
responsive and learn from each other
on what works and what does
not work we explained here
a few days ago that we were in
support of the member states for the  help
to learn lessons from what works and
what does not work and the 21st game I
suppose that precisely this will be an
opportunity for the member states to
take stock of good practices and to
see how to better advance each one at
home but also  all together I cannot
tell you now what the president is
going to say at a meeting which will be
what has just been announced and which will be
held on May 21 what is certain
is that the commission will take stock
of  the advances that we have been able to make
since the beginning
and they are very important and on what
she considers to be the
essential elements to be implemented together
if we want to continue in
controlling her life points knowing
as she said herself that she is
a heroine road a path strewn
with pitfalls and that
we all had to be able to circumvent these
pitfalls in order to arrive safely
indeed difficult situations
maximum efforts but still  once
I repeat it nobody will give up virginie
sorry I will come back to this side fate of
30 million German vaccines since
you repeated to us at the beginning of the
week on several occasions that this
order or desire for orders of 30
million and is integrated  in the lifting of
the 100 million option so
what you were saying at the time was that
there was no order from germany
on its own side for its 30
million players and farsi  you
still that or if finally the story
is that at the beginning it was the
room orders and was reintegrated into the
European orders because I'm
sorry it's not clear thank you virginie I
think I was very  clear at the end
of the inte  rvention Wednesday I said that
I can't you I was not in a position at
that time to say whether or not he had
an agreement what I said was that
our understanding was that the
discussion  on the needs that could
be in europe and in germany on
additional doses we european commission
we were in the process of taking care of it
within the framework of the discussions that we
had with bryant and faïza and I would like
to say all the same what matters this  what
matters is at the end of the day
are we going to have the number
of doses needed or not in a
process that is the first of its
kind in europe as we say in english
look at the big picture see where we
were at  beginning and where we are
today
that is what counts and that is
what we will continue to
focus on
there were preliminary and intermediate stages
of course at a time
when the level of information and
member states and the european union  was
not what it is today
we have made great progress since
then and we are now in a
situation where the european union has been able to
secure 600 million doses of the
bartek kaiser vaccine which will be
distributed over the period  to come
what we believe should also allow
the other vaccines which will be which are
already available to meet
the needs of the needs of
European citizens I give the floor to
yanis I will come back to you at the origin
I do not  don't see your raised hand i
'll come back to 3 yannick hoël yanit 6th
mike sowers and yes we know about the new
order by one we no 5 yanis shelter of as
savior of his family life turn away
from a train that spins millions to
harshness is  that we have band take that
would be 30
virginie i'm coming back to you for your
need sorry i didn't see that you
had a castle yes i'm sorry but
like the city very well christian
today it's 300  m  illions of
additional doses we don't need them
since in any case as
of today the member states have
still not made the vaccines have
still not used all the doses
they will have been delivered because they
are very slow with good movies
so we still have the impression that
this supreme command this new
command
it is made to put out the
controversy in germany and so I
come back to the question how much my
subject you think he is micro
sticky but it's not true do
I think the commission reacted
German policy is so I'm
sorry things are not clear you
have us 10 and 30 million are in
the 100 million there now we are
told I don't know  so I excuse me
a while ago you're going to say ok keep
harping on you harping on you're not looking at
the big picture maybe but no we're
trying to understand what's going on and
I think we're doing in this business but
I guess
far be it from me to say that you're
not doing your job virginie of
course and i'm lying and i'm happy about it
but i answered what i had to
answer to this question i don't deny
that the german authorities can
have a memorandum of understanding
with brendan fraser for a dose for
any dose I invite you to
refer to their statements
on this point what I am telling you is
what the president repeated or said here
in the press room
and what we are emphasizing is that
we have negotiated a number of
additional doses of a vaccine that there
is now authorization from the
european commission following a
positive opinion from the european
medicines
agency years ago  country which wishes to be able to
move forward quickly in terms
of vaccination strategy I hope and
we all hope that vaccinations
will accelerate in all European countries
and therefore to see I remind you
of the possibilities of purchase of the
possibilities of purchase  t then it is the
member states that decide whether they
wish to order these
vaccines
what we do is that we
secure purchasing possibilities the
member states then order
according to their needs
that is what  we have done and
it is in this context that
our approach fits
david yes eric chronicle that surprised by
our remarks but
in fact the european union is a
union which is based on the rules and
today to president  of the
commission said very clearly that having
parallel negotiations and parallel contracts
is against the rules and
within the rules marked that the countries
which choose the parallel way an
opt-out must therefore exit from the
contract of anticipated acquisition  that's
why we insist because sometimes
the rules are applied differently
and 6 and germany
we have the impression in this
particular case that we are trying to protect
someone who has a device made so
here are the reasons for our question and
we are waiting for an answer on this if I
can two other questions since the
hands have announced that we can extract if
dose from each box in the end I do
n't know how much French of the
biotech faiza vaccine I wanted to ask you
if your calculations therefore 300 or 600
million doses are calculated on south
count at 20% more compared to the doses
that you announce last question
is that the commission will buy
doses of vaccine for its staff as
it does with for example the
flu vaccines
thank you thank you on the no what you
mentioned about the European
Medicines Agency I believe that we will come back
to you later because I
don't have everything I don't
have precise information that would allow me
to respond to that if this announcement was
made it must have been there just before the
2010 meeting and therefore we did
not have time to consult with each other
regarding the staff of the
commission I do not  se the floor in basel h
hello so just i only have a few
bit of information in this regard
obviously the question you are asking
this relevant question is very
important and what is also very
important is the health of our
staff  for us so obviously we
are in the process of connecting to a
possible evolving strategy which will
allow us at certain times to vaccinate
our our staff but at the moment
I do not have any details so we are
really in a process of reflection
and we can s  expect that in the
next few weeks
i can or in the
more information but for now that's
all i can say thank you marco
thank you eric i'm not coming back from
the 3 million question because i have
understood that it's you don't want us we
want to answer my question it's on
the stages of the delivery of vaccines
files r because when you have is
the other player you will also see it
missing today the first 200
mill  ions of the doses will be in the booklet
to prevent others will be delivered
before September and the 100 million
that been optioned and will be delivered after
this morning the admission decision told me
that the new to the 300 million
doses part 75  75 million doses
will be available in the first half of
so that's what I don't quite understand
why the first order the 300
million will have to wait until
October to see it but the new
high
is a desert available  a month
before clothes toys 1 can you
clarify thank you you know
negotiations discussions between the
commission and the beatles take place at
different times
there the production capacities which was
that of by night rider was not
necessarily those which have  place
now but a deal that's signed
is a deal that's signed and so you do
n't touch it anymore when you negotiate a
new deal and it can be based
on new facts al  well of course
we try to take it into account and I
think that's what explains the difference
but marco I couldn't give
more details than that I invite you to
I invite you to possibly send
your  questions to the basic management on
their production capacity
you still have to know it's just
to know so some of the
doses of this new one will be available
before as the president of
conditions said the doses of the first other
constraint
finally it's  what the agreements say is
what the agreements say finally one
agreement provides for a certain timetable
the other agreement provides for another
timetable for you to
actually compare to see that some of the
doses of this second agreement that
we are on  the agreement with sorry
ballantine pfizer expects deliveries
before the last deliveries of the
first of the first agreement
does not seem to me in itself
something something exceptional durrani
giovanni it is necessary to change the s  ource of
your microphone tells me we have you hear me yes
here I apologize I'm not going to
break you but it's a question of German dose
here I see a very clear problem
so the commission was at the center of
the action first name very  very far from being
positive of the effect in
european shares of purchase with clear rules
so you are also responsible for that
and there is in the newspapers the problem
that we have the impression that germany
has carried  in an irregular way there
is a lot of irritation on that so
for the commission the commission I
think that with the responsibility must say
if what happened it is normal
because we found a legal clause of
data  in these cases the commission
to say it but if there has been an
infringement we are not talking about a passion
because by a treaty either a
violation of the European agreement on the
part of one of the member states for a
agreement on which the commission
responsible for saying I do not want to answer
we spoke  it with the Germans listen
excuse me I find it too easy so the
commission must have especially after
the president clearly said
officially that the member states
are not the only ones who do not see
the bilateral agreement being made
so I understand that it  is a sound bar
for you but I find that with it
you make the situation even
worse so you have to excuse me I
allow myself but precisely once again
have there been violations of
the agreement  european or not there it is a
question on which you must
answer because you are responsible
for lacrosse otherwise everyone can
think okay we do in europe 1 and
everyone can do what we want
as they want because  that the commission
does nothing as long as I invite you I
beg you once again to go beyond playing
by laying speak with Germany thank you
I have nothing to add to what I have
already said ten times here on the  podium
we focused on the fact in a
crisis  health major to
find agreements with producers to
have as soon as
possible a number of doses that
correspond to the needs of the different
member states
we are confident that
we have succeeded
the president has told you what
the legal situation is  and of course I have nothing to
add
to the president's remarks
on this subject are there any other questions
for us today on other
subjects than this one
thomas walkom bac
roggemans singh from an old and
we  try to one last time and finance his
gestures and looks in touch with about
tonight we go try to a new york
washington
gwenn ha from burkina must be from albert
or zip racing christian from switch 5
[Music]
euros bad faith adalbert au
production fiasco level abilities
[Music]
I told them we want what
we do it's fixed which more than 5 to
6 9 hours of coaching for death wish
you actions  d  u weekend and leave in
michigan asked